قبل ان تجف دماء شهداء ما وصفت بمجزره
مخيم جنين قبل يومين طلق الاحتلال ضربه
ثانيه من اللا مكان من جدران سلوان خرج
صار الفتاه شجره نبتته اوراقت في لحظه
غرسه في ارضه وحوله اغراب اطلق الرصاص
جزعوا تراقضوا في كل صوب جرح مستوطنين
احدهما ضابط كان في عطله قبل ان يصاب
بجروح خطره برصاص الماره وفق التلفزيون
الاسرائيليه والمره هناك هم المستوطنون
المدنيون المسلحون مفارقه اخرى من سمات
اسرائيل الخاصه جنه جنون الاحتلال من يكون
الفتاه انه في الثالثه عشر الجزء الاخر من
الصدمه لكن الاسره التي فات وقالت ان
ابنها كان مرا هناك بالصدفه داهمت قوات
الاحتلال منزلها واعتقلت افرادا من الى
ايا كان اسم المنفذ هو طفل فلسطيني ممن
ينبغي لهم ان يكونوا في مدرسه او نادي
رياضي او يلهو مع اللاهين في لعب الطفوله
لكنها فلسطين حيث لا شيء عاديه ولا طبيعيه
وحيث الاطفال يرون اطفالا تحمل الى
المقابر اجسادا تنزف لقد شاهدهم العالم
ومعه فتاه سلوان قبل اشهر قليله في جبل
وفي غيرها وقبلها وبعدها وكان من
المحمولين منهم في عمره واصغر
في فلسطين يقتل الاطفال ويعلمون على
الطرقات ويعتقلون وحسب الجاني من العقاب
وثائق تسلم للاسره الدوليه عن 52 طفلا
فلسطينيه قتلهم الاسرائيليون العامه
الماضي فقط ومع ذلك لا محكمه جنائيه ولا
لائحه عار بل تساؤل فجر على شكل ص كيف
لهذا العنف اي يكبر في النفوس الصغيره
هجوم سلوان اعقب هجوما هز اركان الحكومه
الموصوفه بالاشد تطرفا في مستوطنه نيفي
يعقوب يوم الجمعه راحت اجهزتها الامنيه
تتعاقب على مواقع الهجوم وظهر الوزير
لتامر بن كثير وسط الحشد لا يسعفه في وجهه
صرخاتهم سوى تمني الموت للعرب والهاتفون
الغاضبون لا يطلبون السلام بل يقرعونه
للتقصير ثم تبدا الافكار والاقتراحات من
راس الهرم بنيامين نتنياهو بترحيل عائلات
المنفذين او اعتقالهم مما يندرج في جريمه
دوليه اخرى اسمها العقاب الجماعيه ماذا
سيفعلون اكثر براي مراقبين فان لها جمات
المنطلقه على شكل فدائيين افراد شبان صغار
من الجيل الثالث او الرابع للاحتلال تضع
اسرائيل كلها
بشقها السياسي ممثلا بحكومه مهتزه والامني
بشقه لاستخباراتيه والعسكريه في الفدائيون
الجدد يعملون وحدهم كل فرد فصيل وكل سلاح
متاح اداه والاجولوجيا كلمتان رفض
الاحتلال اما الجغرافيا ففلسطين كلها كل
بيت وكل عقل وكل روح حره سيكون على العالم
ومن بينه وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه القادم
الى المنطقه ايات معها جيدا في ما وراء
الاجراءات والضغط على السلطه الفلسطينيه
وطلب ضبط النفس من الاحتلال مع صياغات
مكروره عن عمليه سلام ترقد في غيبوبه
الموت ليدرك ان ما يدفع شبابا لدفع الحياه
خلفهم هي ابسط قوانين الطبيعه واشدها
تعقيده الفعل ورد الفعل الاحتلال
والمقاومه
[موسيقى]